Another legacy Marvel character may be about
to come bubbling to the surface of the MCU.
A scene early in Avengers: Endgame seems like
it could be a hidden tease for the impending
arrival of Namor the Sub-Mariner, one of Marvel's
oldest characters.
An anti-hero with an 80-year publication history,
Namor has served as both a nemesis and an
ally to a laundry list of iconic Marvel heroes.
Spoilers for Avengers: Endgame to follow,
obviously.
Fans have long wondered whether Namor the
Sub-Mariner would ever make an appearance
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, and Endgame
may have actually given us our answer… kind
of.
During the scene in question, Scarlett Johansson's
Natasha Romanoff is convening a holographic
council of heroes, who are scattered after
the five-year time jump.
One of the participants is Okoye, who appears
to be holding Wakanda together in the absence
of the dusted King T'Challa.
She reports seismic activity on the floor
of the Atlantic Ocean, under the African plate,
which apparently falls under Wakanda's jurisdiction.
When asked by Romanoff how she intends to
handle it, Okoye says, "It's an earthquake
under the ocean.
We handle it by not handling it."
At first it seems like a throwaway line, but
if we know Marvel, it was included for a purpose
— and we have a couple key pieces of evidence
to back up our assertion.
The fact that the disturbance was reported
by Okoye is telling, as Wakanda and Atlantis
have a bit of a history in the comics — that
is to say, they don't get along, and have
actually gone to war on more than one occasion.
Not only that, in the second issue of the
original Infinity Gauntlet miniseries, an
undersea earthquake occurs in the wake of
Thanos's snap — and none other than Namor,
the Sub-Mariner, is on hand to investigate.
More importantly than all that, though, is
the fact that Marvel Studios is well-known
for "planting seeds" which suggest the possibility
of characters that might up come into play
down the line, and this particular seed was
not the first one that's been planted in the
MCU concerning Namor.
Way back in 2010's Iron Man 2, there was a
scene in which Nick Fury and Tony Stark discussed
tentative plans to scout for the team that
would soon become the Avengers.
During their conversation, Fury was referring
to a series of holographic screens, many of
which depicted events from the past and the
future in the MCU.
But one screen was simply a world map which
showed various "hot spots" around the globe
which had garnered the interest of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
and one of these spots happened to be located…
smack in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean.
Of course, it's almost certain that at the
time that particular Easter egg was dropped,
nobody had any idea whether Namor would ever
come into play in the MCU.
But the inclusion of Okoye's report in Avengers:
Endgame suggests that Marvel Studios might've
kept the character in mind this entire time...and
that they may now be prepping us for his formal
introduction.
Speaking of introductions...
Namor first appeared in Motion Picture Funnies
Weekly #1, a promotional publication handed
out to movie theaters all the way back in
April 1939.
This book was, in fact, the very first to
ever be published by the company that would
later become Marvel Comics, making Namor not
just a legacy character, but the legacy character.
Namor's origin story and characteristics are
quite similar to that of DC's Aquaman, who
wouldn't appear until November of 1941.
The half-human son of an Atlantean princess,
he's a prince and later king of that underwater
realm whose mistrust of the surface world
runs deep.
He's super-strong, super-tough, and — yes
— he can also communicate with marine life.
So yeah...in all ways that matter, he's basically
the original Aquaman.
But this guy can fly.
"That was the worst pep talk.
Ever."
Given the huge success Warner Bros. saw with
Aquaman, it wouldn't be a huge stretch for
Marvel Studios to try and show their superheroic
rivals their own take on an undersea adventure.
Meanwhile, with the death of Iron Man, the
retirement of Captain America, and the departure
of Thor for space with the Guardians of the
Galaxy, Marvel still needs some action to
go down on earth.
What better character to bring onto the scene
than their original superguy, Namor?
Not only that, but Marvel finally has access
to the Fantastic Four, now that Disney has
acquired 20th Century Fox.
Considering Namor's deep ties to the FF in
the comics, the time might finally be right
for Marvel's undersea king to show the surface
world who's boss.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.